e
all right um it's beyond 9:30 so I'm
going to call the uh house J Judiciary
Committee to order and first I would
recognize representative trip to lead us
allegiance aliance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
all all right all right um so first I'm
going to open the hearing on uh
Constitutional Amendment concurrent
resolution number seven relating to the
presumption of innocence and I recognize
uh the prime sponsor
representative thank you Mr chair and
thank you for the committee for the
record my name is uh representative
Kelly penzer straford District 19
Rochester Awards 1 23 4 and six
um I'm just going to go into my
testimony just because um it's a little
lengthy and um so giving people the
option to vote on amending the New
Hampshire Constitution to explicitly
state that in all cases and suits of the
State against one of the people the
defendant shall be innocent until proven
guilty is important for several reasons
it strengthenings due Pro it strengthens
due process while the presumption of
innocent is already a fundamental
principle in American law explicitly
adding it to the state constitution
reinforces the commitment to protect
individuals from wrongful convictions
and unjust government actions preventing
government overreach by enshrining this
principle the amendment ensures that the
state always carries the burden of proof
preventing potential abuses where
individuals might be presumed guilty
without sufficient evidence clarifying
legal standards some legal procceed
proceedings such as civil asset
forfeiture or certain regulatory
violations may not afford defendants the
same presumption of innocence as
criminal cases this amendment could help
ensure broader application of this
principle empowering voters giving
people the opportunity to vote on this
issue promotes the Democratic process
and participation and allows citizens to
directly influence how Justice it is
administered in their state five setting
a precedent for other states if pass
this amendment could encourage other
states to take similar steps reinforcing
constitutional protections Nationwide
the principle of innocent until proven
guilty unless proven guilty is already a
Cornerstone of the US legal system
primarily recognized in criminal law
however adding this explicitly to the
New Hampshire Constitution would
strengthen its application in a few ways
current US in New Hampshire legal
standards the fifth and 14th amendments
of the US Constitution provide due
process rights and ensuring that no
person is deprived of life liberty or
property without legal procedures the
presumption of innocence is a is a
principle recognized in US courts
primarily based on precedent rather than
an explicit constitutional
provision the New Hampshire Constitution
part one Bill of Rights already includes
protection related to due process and
legal fairness but this amendment would
make the presumption of innocence
explicitly clear in all state actions
against individual
why this amendment matters it closes
legal gaps while criminal cases follow
the presumption of innocence some
administrative and civil actions by the
state may place the burden on
individuals to prove their innocence
this amendment could reinforce fairness
in such
cases as I already talked about in
limiting potential government overreach
without this explicit language further
legislation or judicial rulings might
shift the burden unfairly in certain C
situations such as regulatory violation
or forfeit cases and it prevents legal
erosion codifying the presumption of
innocence in the state constitution
ensures that it remains a fundamental
right regardless of political or legal
shifts at the federal level so in
comparison with other states and some
historical examples while um the
presumption of innocence is
wellestablished principle in US criminal
law it's not explicitly stated in the US
Constitution instead it comes from case
law particularly in 1895 a Supreme Court
decision coffen versus United States
which affirmed that defendants must be
presumed innocent until proven guilty
Beyond A Reasonable Doubt some states
have taken steps to reinforce or expand
this principle through Constitutional
Amendments or legal reforms Louisiana in
2018 they voted to overturn a law that
allowed um non-un unanimous jury
verdicts and felony trials reinforcing
the idea that defendants should have
full protections under the law Texas and
Michigan they have constitutional
language that protects due process but
doesn't explicitly State a universal
presumption of
innocence um historical cases where this
principle was challenged uh civil asses
for forfeiture Nationwide in many cases
law enforcement can seize property
suspected of being connected to a crime
without requiring a criminal conviction
critics argue that this flips the burden
onto individuals to prove their
innocence a constitutional amendment in
New Hampshire could make such practices
more difficult interment of the Japanese
Americans in World War II that's katsu
versus the US the US government detained
thousands of Japanese Americans without
individual trials violating due process
if stronger constitutional Pro
protections had been in place such
actions could have been legally
challenged more effectively post 911
detentions case of indefinite detention
such as those under the US Patriot Act
raise concerns about presumption of
innocence being bypassed in National
Security cases
cases so how could we set a precedent if
passed this amendment would make New
Hampshire one of the first states to
explicitly enslin this protection in our
constitution other states may follow uh
leading to National conversation about
reinforcing legal protections Beyond
just criminal trials and it could be
used in legal challenges where the
government places an unfair burden on
individuals in civil or administrative
matters I'd like to um make reference to
three uh three amendments to the New
Hampshire Constitution uh part one
Article 2 in natural rights it was
amended in 1974 to add equality of
rights under the law shall not be denied
or bridged by this state on account of
race Creed color sex or national origin
uh part um part one article 2A the
bearing of arms was added in December
1st of 1982 all persons have the right
to keep and bear arms in defense of
themselves their families their property
in the state and one of I think the most
important one that was added recently
was part one article 2B the right of
privacy an individual's right to live
free from governmental intrusion in
private or personal information is
natural essential and
inherent as you hopefully read in
honorable Dan it says testimony our
constitution is very clear in criminal
cases part one Article 15
no subject shall be arrested imprisoned
is spoiled or deprived of his property
immunities or privileges put out of the
protection of the law exiled or deprived
of his life liberty or estate but by the
Judgment of his peers or the law of the
land the law of the land is the common
law an example of why this is needed
during the late 20th century Child
Protection was moved out of criminal
court and into a civil court then in
1995 a dedicated equity Court civil
court for this purpose was instituted
this is where everything went wrong the
common law foundational law maximums are
nowhere to be found in our family court
system these maximums of common law were
intended to protect individuals against
the
overwhelming overwhelmingly power of the
state um are suspended and they're
basically suspended in Family Court the
jurisdiction of Family Court 490 D3
States explicitly that nothing shall
require the facts to be framed by rules
in equity or according to the common law
today in our state children are being
separated from their parents parental
powers and rights being terminated
without an ounce of the Cornerstone in
our Judicial System the Cornerstone
being innocent unless proven guilty
evidence that is being supplied to prove
innocence or intended malice from the
plaintiff SL state is frequently brushed
aside
ignored or flat out refused by the
courts there is no greater Liberty issue
than of your own life or your children's
lives we need to put this element of
common law reserved for the people into
our constitution so it is beyond
legislative meddling our only job as
Representatives is to protect the rights
of the people we took an oath to both
the New Hampshire and US constitutions
to do so we work for the people and only
for them them many in the legislature
have forgotten that this is our only job
here so my question to all of you is
this do you believe that people Accused
by the state in criminal or civil court
are innocent until proven guilty if the
answer to that question is yes please
pass this in your committee if the
answer to that question is no are you
willing to tell the people of New
Hampshire that the state can accuse them
and they will need to prove their
innocence rather than the state proving
their guilt we learned a lot from the
recent Supreme Court decision it was the
bruan decision that came out in June of
2022 Bruin marks a return to the general
law approach common foundational law
under which courts look quote to history
and custom to understand the right for
example under this view legislates could
not create sensitive places that
effectively deny people their
constitutional right to bear arms out
the home the historical litmus test is
important in this issue and we've seen
the courts move in that direction for
the last two to three years I thank you
for your time and I'm welcome to take
any
questions questions for this witness yes
representative
Oregon yes thank you very much uh Mr
chair thank you very much representative
on the one hand this amendment is very
timely given you know what's going on
Nationwide some pretty dramatic stuff
but on the other hand we're year early
because we can't vote on it until
November 26
and and um I also don't so that mean
that so are you intending for us maybe
to take some time to think about exactly
how to word it like for example I'm not
quite sure what this phrase one of the
people means so um so can maybe
elucidate uh like what one of the people
thanks um throughout throughout both
constitutions it talks about um it talks
about the people versus um and natural
rights of the people versus um the
government so I think that's what um um
basically the Constitution is written
for the people and for their rights um
to protect of course government
encroachment I do know that this falls
under voting in 26 and uh I'm just
getting a jump on
it thanks other questions for this
Witness
seeing none I I guess I have a couple of
questions um the the first question I
have is
um
you can you give us any ex you you say
for example if I'm understanding
correctly that in the family courts in
child abuse cases the courts are PL am I
understanding that you're saying the
courts are placing the burden on the
person who's accused of of having
committed some kind of abuse to
establish that they're innocent it's not
just in abuse cases it could be in in
custody cases and things like that so
yes and that is definitely happening and
I can give you multitudes of examples so
here's my here's my question I'm just
you know I when I heard that of this
amendment coming up I went did a little
research and I'm looking now at the
abuse and neglect statute and I refer to
RSA 169 C13 which says the petitioner
that is the state or whoever is filing
to you know to to say that the child has
been abused has the burden to prove the
allegations in support of the petition
by a preponderance of the evidence so I
guess I'm what I'm really not clear on
is if you're saying that courts are not
following the current law which very
clearly says that the burden is on the
state I guess my question is how is this
going to help if we pass a
constitutional amendment why won't they
too it's just one step in the many and I
think that um hopefully uh with the
historical content of of how things are
um being used now that this could be
referred to um going up to a higher
court level maybe even out of our own um
Court Juris that we can use this um in a
in a federal manner um there's there has
been unbelievable amounts of evidence
that's refused I'm working with a
constituent right now and every single
thing he just had another hearing was
ignored the judge decided he wasn't
going to look at any of it none of it he
hasn't seen his children in almost a
year and there's nothing there's no
restraining order there's nothing
against him it doesn't make any sense so
can I just ask you and you the
information that you're just that you've
just relayed to us about this case this
you know constituent or whatever um were
did you talk to the other side of the
case in other words do you you've got if
I'm understanding correctly you've
gotten the perspective of one side of
the case and it sounds like from what
you're saying presumably the the side
that didn't Prevail so my question
is you are you how are you able to make
an accurate assessment of whether that's
true if you haven't talked to the other
side of the case you haven't heard what
the other side had to say this isn't
about me taking sides this is about
literally not using the evidence at hand
it being ignored that's the reason my
question is how do you know that it was
ignored I I've read the court
transcripts I was there and I was there
at the court hearing okay and so the I
watched it firsthand so you are so and
and so and did the judge give a reason
for why he was not or she was not uh
hearing the evidence no she did not okay
all right and you say that this is
something that has happened routinely
multitudes of times okay all right and I
will give you whatever you need I will
spend the next five days providing all
of that information for you yeah I I
would appreciate it if you could get you
say you've looked at the transcript I
would appreciate I'd like to see the
transcript if you wouldn't mind
providing it okay all right great um
other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
are there any other Witnesses who wish
to be heard on cacr
7 seeing none I'm going to close the
probably do you have is that written
testimony that you consider that would
be lovely thank
you yes that was a lot of information
clerk
all
um right so let me ask you we have we
have about five minutes um I'd like to
um while we have that time turn to um
and open an executive session on House
Bill
480 that was the bill that um we heard
last week by repes was representative
Pearson testifying it's the bill
um that would establish um uh the
um oh what is the name of it the the it
was it establishes a procedure for uh
restoring competency and it calls for
the uh pilot
program uh to establish in either marac
or or straford County to establish a
forensic liaison position to assist in
restoring competence idency
um I think when we had um a a brief
discussion about it last week um
representative uh Pell had a question
about you know wanted to sort of look at
it a little bit further um I think she's
now had that as I understand it had the
chance to do that so it seemed like we
were all generally in agreement on this
um with the with the exception of the
concerns representative pedal had and I
my understanding and I'll let her speak
for herself is she has satisfied her
concerns and is now okay with it um so
if we are all generally in consensus I
would propose to exact the bill and take
a vote on it now is there anybody that
has a problem with doing that I have no
problem at all we do have a quum my only
question is since there're only 11 of us
um do you think that it is a right
assuming Jo's bad
um it would be better to have more
people here and I'm not I'm not
prejudging the answer I'm just raising
the question no I I hear what you're
saying I guess my sense is that you know
we when we did have more some people who
are not here today my recollection is
nobody had any any issues so I agree
with that and for example representative
tur who was not here here because he's
at another important legislative related
meeting um was actually on the that's
right he was on this that's right and
isn't is a sponsor of the bill and I
believe repres actually I believe
representative kutab was if if she was
not she was either on the committee or
certainly is is very spor to intimately
familiar with it so I don't think so and
given those to go ahead I don't see any
of my colleagues expressing any concern
I do want to mention that we have
received um an email um from um the
disabilities rights center right saying
that they felt that they had not been
included
um and I I read it and I understand what
they said
um but I'm not sure that other than
recognizing their absolute right to have
expressed their concern about that that
in fact
um affected the outcome now that that
that was my sense too but representative
Rao representative Smith covered what I
wanted I just wanted to mention the
email we had all receiv I saw I saw that
also and I you know I didn't know if
there were any concerns about that or
right yeah I me just it seemed to me I
mean it
it you know I I obviously I was not a
member of that sub but I it it really
did seem to me both from my from
representative Pearson's testimony and
just discussions that I've had um with
representative uh uh kab um that you
know that there was very representative
Pearson Tred to get the broadest
possible input from various factors
various uh places and it seemed like you
know he achieved that so um unless
anybody has any strong objection I would
propose yes representative Andrew thank
you Mr chair I have a strong
objection in executive session normally
when we advertise it we make sure we
have 20 people here and today we have
eight
missing and they they may all be in
favor of the bill but I just don't think
it's fair to exact a bill with so many
of us missing and if we're going to
exact bills then maybe we need to fill
the chairs with the you know appro
substitutes that's just my opinion okay
um well does anybody else have that if
anybody yes representative ber thank you
Mr chair I have a very broad question
and I'm not exactly sure who to ask but
at this point in time if a bill like
this and I'm not sure what your thought
methodology is but when a bill like this
happens and all of a sudden it takes
like everybody starts reading about it
and what if it becomes this big deal I
mean does legal look at these so it's
okay or we're
legal cuz I know on other places I've
been it's like we do our thing and then
pass it to legal to make sure it's
worded correctly or whatnot so we can't
get in trouble but I was just confusing
um yeah I I was just curious if that's
part of the procedure is having I know
we don't have attorneys kicking around
but no go go ahead represent I'll I'll
let
you good question um
the legislature makes the
law and um there are times when the
legislature
isn't 100%
comfortable and although I don't agree
with this they then go through what I
refer to as Mommy mayi and that is to
ask the Supreme Court for a decision as
to whether X Y or Z is appropriate other
uh so and and we you know when the the
bills are drafted you know there are all
kinds of people
Whose advice is sought but um so it's a
little different from another
environment I appreciate it all right so
let me um ask if if um representative
Andrew has has expressed some concern
about doing this if if if that would
lead representative Andrew to vote no
that would be a a 10 to one vote which
would still be sufficient you can vote I
just want yeah no no I hear you I you
know I guess what I would say
representative Andrew is this I would
not I would not do this if we had not
discussed this last week and the people
who are missing did not express any
objection to proceeding but it seems to
me given that they didn't and that the
only person who had a concern and
perfectly legitimate concern
representative predel has now studied
the bill and and you know her concerns
are resolved I think there really is an
interest in proceeding and I I guess you
know one of the things I that that I
think is really important to emphasize
is I think not only today uh but you
know going forward with the rest of the
days of hearings it will be really
important for this committee to try to
exec as many bills as you can exec um
you know as quickly as possible
because in early March we're going to
have a lot of work to do and to the
extent we can you know remove bills uh
early I think it is in everybody's
interest to do that representative
peder thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to um speak for myself that yes I
have had an opportunity to review this
amendment and um in support of it
however I'm looking in my um Bill file
and I noticed that we don't have a
member of the committee
whose name is on this amendment so we
would need to have that I believe before
we can actually introduce and vote on it
is representative
Pearson's no
off Comm off all right so I guess I I
would propose to go for to go ahead with
the exec on this bill and so first um I
will move Amendment first you have to
move
otpa right for right I will move
Amendment
61h um as an amendment to House Bill
480 um and is there a second for that I
second it all right so but I believe
your motion your your motion was
otpa I'm I'm sorry OTP yes it was which
I second and then
yes and so I um all right so the motion
has been made and seconded uh on the uh
Amendment uh and can I just ask for a
show of hands of all those in favor of
amendment
hand looks like unanimous
um I thought representative Anders I
thought you did raise your hand did I
yeah okay yeah all
right all right and so we're now then on
to um the the main motion of uh ought to
pass as amended um anyone wish to be
heard any further on
that right seeing none I would ask the
clerk then to please call the role on
the motion being otpa on House Bill 480
with Amendment 2025
61h representative Manion yes
representative Alexander representative
trip yes representative Andrew
yes representative Smith
yes representative Horan yes
representative pay
yes representative Romo
yes and representative berson
yes 10 Ys one
nay all right um so the motion uh motion
carries um since I was up early this
morning and actually have the report
written I'll write I'll write the I'll
write the report you made the motion
right you were going to ask me to other
no no
no um all
right no not consent is there um
representative Andrew says no to consent
no all right so it will not I don't know
that it it would go on consent anyway
because it it is even though it's not a
money Bill now it is gonna clearly go to
finance so I think we we're better off
not having it on consent anyway um uh
representative Andrew uh do you plan to
write a Minority Report no okay all
good all right good well thank you I'm
glad we at least got that out of the way
and I know representative Pearson will
be happy about that also all right um
next we're on to uh chter 10 and I'm
going to open the hearing on House Bill
666 FN relative to adding uh restitution
payments for violations of the
confidentiality of the library use
records and uh adding library cards and
membership status to the list of
confidential matters and I recognize
representative
sorry thank you Mr chair and honorable
members of the committee good morning
for the record my name is Lisa merer
representing Hillsboro District 44 gtown
and where I'm going to start by saying
don't hold the bill number 666 against
me I did not ask for
that um I could not change it
so all right so first of all thank you
for passing HB 376 on consent last week
that was a big privacy win for present
and future Library users not only in go
down but throughout our entire state so
that bill this is part two of that bill
so that bill addressed expanding 91a
colon 5 to clarify that library cards
and Library membership statuses are
exempt from right to no requests this
bill addresses RSA 2011 dco and 11 which
pertains to the confidentiality of
Library user records currently the RSA
language reads and I quote
Library records which contain the names
or other personal identifying
information regarding the users of
public or other than public libraries
shall be con shall be confidential and
shall not be disclosed such records
include but are not limited to library
information system and archival Records
related to the circulation and use of
Library materials or services including
record of materials that have been
viewed or stored in electronic form end
quote again it appears the current law
is pretty straightforward in keeping
library cards confidential but our town
apparently did not think so so this
further clarifies
that this bill copies the exact same
verbiage as 91a colon 5 to read such
records include but are not limited to
library cards and Library membership
status etc for
consistency this bill also adds a
restitution payment as a penalty for
violations of disclosing this private
information adding restitution as a
remedy ensures that individuals harmed
by such breaches have a clear Avenue for
relief which the people in our town did
not Financial penalties also serve as a
deterrent a deterrent rein en forcing
the seriousness of protecting Library
users libraries are cornerstones of
intellectual freedom and privacy patrons
must feel confident that their reading
habits research inquiries and membership
status remain confidential the current
law provides some protection but
additional measures are needed to deter
violations and address harm when
breaches occur which the current law
does not by extending confidentiality
protections to these aspects we align
PRI Library privacy standards with
broader protections for p personally
identifiable information I urge this
committee to adopt these enhancements to
safeguard the privacy and trust that are
fundamental to the role of libraries in
our communities thank you for your
consideration and I welcome any
questions questions for this witness yes
representative Rambo thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um for the uh restitution the
Fe the new paragraph um is there any
intentionality or um knowing uh sort of
or did you contemplate that kind of
language in terms of this was actually
done through the our drafting attorney
and and so he went through the proper
recourse to decide to figure out an
amount that would be uh not not a
financial liability to people but also
as I mentioned a deterrent yeah so I'm
sorry I don't think I asked the question
very clearly um if there was an
unintentional
disclosure how does that work with the
restitution thing I'm not sure what you
me is it a penalty in terms of like a
knowing disclosure as opposed to someone
accidentally disclosing are they still
liable for the how would you
accidentally disclose a library
card I mean I
can I'm just spitballing here but like
some sort of data breach some sort of
something some sort of recordkeeping
error and an off office or I I'm just I
think there's scenario as I could
imagine so I just so a data breach a g
gdpr breach I believe is a whole
different situation this is someone
intentionally filing a right to know to
request and and publish someone's
personal private information and in our
in the case in our town it was they were
weaponizing library because it's it's
part two of falling under the right to
know umbrella okay exactly okay I
appreciate that yeah then the other
other question oh sorry I can't do that
I can't do that sorry you have another
question I do have one it's just it's
very narrow you don't mind thank you
where you cross out or we otherwise U
required by Statute can you tell me
about striking out that yes so there's
there's other places in statute where um
you can library cards can be released
via court order or if someone's under
investigation so that's that's another
area of Statute so this this would say
that like if if that pertained then this
doesn't apply so you can you can ask you
can get someone's library card uh you
know someone can come in if they're if
they have something going on them that
the law needs that information yes y
representative
Smith I'm sorry representative ber on
next
no thank you for being here and your
sense of humor I just wanted to know as
far as like education for example we
have so many school you know with
schools does any of that apply to the
kind of privacy that students like in in
their school or thank you for that
question I wish it did this law
specifically this RSA 2011 dco and 11
specifically addresses confidentiality
of Library users so I don't believe
that's the public school
library um this is these are this is
public pertaining to public public
libraries like Town libraries so and I
don't have the answer for the schools
all right representative Smith thank you
um thank you very much um for explaining
this to us do you see any
exceptions other than those that you
identified for
um uh that are already noted in the rsas
yes thank you children adults yes thank
you representative orgon um yes there is
a reference to a court order in um part
two but that's um but that's uh that's a
court order explicitly allowing the
library card usage to be divulged but
how do you prove that the information
was divulged without consented
individual or and how do you prove who
did it and um so what's and also so um
how did you arrive at the fine which
seems like a fairly excessive fine so
might dissuade people from volunteering
at their local library yeah so how but
how can you start with your first
question yeah and then I'll yeah okay
what's the first one again well how do
you how do you how do you prove what's
the procedure for proving that this
happened that this information was in
fact actually divulged and then who
divulged it and then also like okay well
give you the example that happened in
our town um a right to know was filed by
the wife of our select board chair and
we didn't the the people that it
happened to all all six Library
candidates actually had no idea that
that had happened except that the next
thing we knew they were all over social
media the library cards so the the the
candidates were how the heck what is
happening so the candidates or one of
them filed a right to know with the
library saying how did how did this come
to this that's where we found out who
had filed the original right to know for
the information our select board's
wife's chair chair's wife had requested
them um so that's how we found that out
through a right to know and that's and
then so what's your second question well
you you actually have a follow the uh
well the fine that seems like an
excessive fine but also you rais the
question then and um is there this is
there an exception for in the context of
a political campaign what if you have
like very contentious campaign for
Library board trusty and somebody
accuses one of the other candidates of
uh of not having a library card so can
that would that could that lead to the
candidate being fined I I believe
someone brought that up in in the he the
hearing last week is so let's say
someone runs for Budget committee are
can we ask for someone's bank card to
prove prove that they they have some
sort of you know handling of money
experience I mean in what other areas
are we asking people to prove something
with using their private information to
do so it was mentioned that if people
want to you know come up and ask a
candidate if that's the case then that's
their prerogative to do so but
publishing it all over the Internet and
everywhere else is not the way okay can
I get back to like or represent man
representative man thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um so
we heard earlier about a bill about
parents receiving information on minor
child's Library information or status is
that outside of this bill is or is that
outside of 91a that first you familiar
with absolutely so that would be exempt
from this yes okay thank you yeah that's
a whole different thing other questions
for this witness you know I I guess I
have a question on with regard
to um section four the the the penalty
provision
um I have no problem with saying any
library or Library staff member I guess
I have some question about any member of
the public in other words is am I
understanding that this would mean that
if if I as a member of the public know
from whatever from somebody telling me
or whatever um that you have a library
card I'm prohibited from saying to
anyone else
um representative Missour has a library
card why well publicizing it so I mean
that's it says discloses so disclosers
could mean I tell representative Oregon
I've disclosed it well I I don't think
that's appropriate to do that um and in
our in the case in our town it was a
member of the general public who
submitted a right to know and then
published it all over the Internet she
disclosed that private information
without our consent it's one thing if
you give consent to people to do that
that would be like you know disclosing
any other private information that you
told someone in confidence and then
they're putting it out to the world
right I mean I guess what I'm getting I
guess what I understand what you're
conern concerned about with the right to
know and we've I think we've probably
addressed that with the other bill that
we've you know to say you can't that's
going to be confidential information but
what I'm saying is this seems to me to
say that I can't however I got for
example you
might suppose that you know
your husband daughter relative tells me
in the course of casual conversation
that you have a library card and I tell
representative Horgan this would seem to
me to say that I could be H liable for
doing that mhm I mean if it's if um the
committee would be amendable I can I can
change that disclose word to you know
who
publishes um publicly
publishes information but I guess I'm my
concern is just gen the basically the
idea of saying any member of the public
yeah um that's because that's what
happened in our town and it I mean it
went viral those cards and and there
were people is there a First Amendment
issue here that in other words a member
you're telling me that as a member of
the public I I haven't gotten you know I
haven't broken into or made an improper
91a request or anything I just I'm a
member of the public and I have
information that you have a library card
is there is there a First Amendment
problem with you're saying I cannot tell
somebody this is a privacy issue but if
I know it's no longer private I know
that information well now that's the
case in our town everybody knows who
does and who doesn't it's to prevent
that in the future because it's you know
let's say someone's this is a a silly
analogy but let's say someone running
for Budget committee you know stashes
all of their money you know under their
Mattress versus use utilizing a bank for
it and someone knows that information
like I guess that
could you know go wherever it is but it
just I don't know it just rep
representative Alexander represent
Alexander thank you Mr chair um would
the sponsor be amendable to an amendment
that would drop section two and just
maintain section one to clarify so drop
the penalty because I think that was
where the a lot of the questions are
coming from and just leave section one
would the sponsor be amendable to that I
would be amendable to that it sounds
though like that it's just that word who
discloses that discloses word yeah well
you know I I I mean I guess what I would
say I don't have any problem I mean I
actually think that the idea of having
some kind of a penalty is probably a
good idea if you want to you know I but
my only concern was how broad it would
be because you know the analogy that I
would draw is this I think I know in
many states and I think it's true in New
Hampshire somebody can correct me if I'm
wrong whether you have a pistol permit
even though you don't need one anymore
you can still get one whether you have a
pistol permit is is that the police are
not supposed to disclose that right but
if I if I know from some source that you
have a pistol permit and I say and I
tell you know representative burgon oh
representative Missouri has a pistol
permit can I be held liable for that if
I didn't get it I didn't get any I
didn't break into and and take any
confidential information I just know
that you have a pistol permit it that
just seems to me to be awfully
awfully broad I think I'm just a staunch
defender of privacy and this what we
experienced in our town and there are
many on both sides of the aisle that
agreed that this was an egregious breach
of privacy especi especially publishing
them all over the place I guess it's but
then it it is if you know you keep going
down this path and it's just a con
people will then just start
this will become just a thing in our
elections and beyond that people start
weaponizing private information to win
elections and and this is just not the
way this is just a small step in trying
to trying to have that not happen again
and by putting a penalty on it um that
because right now what's what's the
repercussion of it nothing a little slap
on the hand big deal they'll just
continue to do it again so that that was
this um
if if
you if you would like to amend it in a
way that makes it
more zoned in on
just the you know the library card
versus membership status I that's a
possibility as
Welles Alexander thank you Mr chair I'm
happy to um while you're traveling in
Southeast Asia Workshop this bill and
get it to a a good point if that's what
you prefer yeah yeah no no that that
that'd be great um other questions for
this witness I I just want
representative Smith thank you I just
want to point out how easy it is to
share information that perhaps isn't
necessarily public for example where one
traveling right um all right I don't see
any other questions thank thank you very
much representative M so
so you know what what I would say uh
representative uh Alexander is
I the things that I would obviously the
subcommittee can do what it pleases and
it'll come back before the committee but
what I would suggest it would be
appropriate to think about would be
perhaps just removing the reference to a
member of the public number one and the
second thing that I would suggest you
might want to think about
is restitution in the law has a
particular meaning it means you've like
been har you know to give you back a um
something that you've that you've lost
and I would think as really as as you
said I think a couple times in your
testimony representative M this is
really intended as sort of a civil
penalty so I would say it might be
better to just refer to it instead of
saying restitution refer to it as a
civil penalty a $500 civil penalty can I
just something you said it's to address
something that someone's lost well many
people have lost trust through this
process so yes something was lost in
this breach yeah I'm not sure that that
would be the kind of thing that you
could measure to you know I I think it
really as you isn't the idea here to
sort of a sanction it's not it's it I
mean even if the person you know suppose
in the example the person you know
actually who was disclosed not to have a
library card won an overwhelming victory
in the election for Library trustee I
mean you do you want to say do you want
to say well no no no you didn't you
didn't lose anything you you actually
you know you you won a slam dunk an
overwhelming Victory you'd still want
them to pay the to have to pay wouldn't
you all right so that's why I'm just
saying it might Mak more sense to call
it a civil penalty CU that's kind of
what it is and I wouldn't have
personally I wouldn't have any problem
with that just myself that it was there
were several other people that were
involved in this and there was no course
of action that that there was nothing
that could be taken we tried the
Ombudsman thing that was six months of
wasted time um and then we don't we're
not going to pay a lot of money for a
court action when in our it it was I've
the current law to us seemed so clear I
just so this just
tightens it up and we heard from right
to know New Hampshire in the last
hearing that they agreed that they can't
believe that clarification is needed on
this but apparently it is and they
agreed with
that other questions for this witness
yes representative um I would just chime
in very quickly and express the
opinion I guess it's okay to do so now
that $500 might be an excessive uh
penalty for this violation too so we we
want something that's not so large that
it will start dissuading people from
taking a low paying job at the library
or being a volunteer or so forth they're
just fair point if that was a I'm sorry
if that was a question I'll say no
that's to dissuade people from releasing
people's private information that's what
that is it might it might have it okay
all right yeah we don't we want I think
we don't want to have a debate here on
that um all right any other questions
for this witness thank you
representative Missour any are there any
other Witnesses who wish to be heard on
House Bill 666
FN seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on House Bill 666 FN and we have
no
e
I'm going to open the hearing on House
Bill 687
FN um hang on one second and um
represent uh recognized representative
corkrin the prime sponsor thank you uh
Representatives so uh this bill is
pretty simple uh and best of all it has
zero cost associated with it and uh what
it does is just put in restrictions on
where funds from class action
settlements can be directed uh this is a
problem that my research has shown uh
hasn't been too much of an issue in New
Hampshire but is in several other states
and has been at the federal level um
often there will be a situation where a
class action lawsuit is driven not So
Much by uh huge claims to the plaintiffs
although there are certainly going to be
some claims uh damages or it wouldn't
get anywhere um but are driven largely
by uh lawyers sometimes lawyers
associated with an activist cause so uh
one example might be that um milk has
been mislabeled it's been labeled as 4%
uh fat and it's actually you know
3.92% fat and testing has shown this and
the uh attorneys and the activists will
go out sort of effectively shopping for
a plain of class um and you know they
will either you know find 500 people to
sign up or have their activist list of
people who are always happy to say yes I
bought a gallon of milk and I feel that
I was damaged by not getting the full
percent of butter
fat the damages in such a situation um
might not be you know hugely
quantifiable but there'll be number
arrived at and then uh the courts will
often not want to cut checks of 2.3
cents uh to each of 10,000 plaintiffs um
and the uh attorneys will say oh you
know of course you don't the overhead on
that would be outrageous let's do
something useful with the settlement the
$100,000 of settlement should really go
to the vegans for Farm law reform or you
know something like that and you can
picture this in various directions um
it's not necessarily A you know leftwing
activist right-wing activist can do this
as well
um and the you know intent of class
action lawsuits is good where any one
person has some degree of harms you know
there's radon in my basement or there's
a defective bumper on my truck and I did
in fact suffer $200 of damages from this
um but it would never be worth $225,000
in attorney fees to write this uh wrong
uh so the intent of class action
lawsuits is that by consolidating all of
these cases and consolidating all of the
harms but only going through one uh
lawsuit um that you know sort of justice
has arrived at without a huge amount of
friction and the uh intent of this sort
of minor uh clarification which brings
us in line with a few other states that
have such things is there can in fact be
you know such lawsuits these are a good
useful tool uh but we want to make sure
that the actual intent of a class action
lawsuit uh is achieved and not some
other intent that's sort of riding in
the form of a legitimate class action
lawsuit and uh I would invite any
seeing none thank you very much sir
thank you for your
time is there anyone else um who wishes
687 seeing none I'm going to close the
687 could I ask a question of um anyone
who might be a former member of the
judicial
brand yes you may thank you would you I
Cypress not being an attorney could you
explain to
me the
relevance
in in in
this legislation yeah I think um and
please understand I don't profess to be
but thank you for that now I've learned
something good but um basically I I
think it is it is a judicial doctrine
that's been around I think really for
centuries and it allows the court um let
me give you an example which comes to
mind you may remember the the um the
Youth Development Center oh yes the uh I
think it's the Youth Development Center
the
I think that I think I've got that right
so the the
originally the land that that was on was
was U
donated um
to I I'm not I'm either the city of
mansion I'm not sure who or the state it
was donated for certain purposes to be
used
for um and and I'm just making this up
because I don't frankly remember but
there to be be used for let's say to be
used for um uh the establishment of a
school let's say and let's say for one
reason or another there is no longer a
need for the school in other words
there's you know the the the educational
needs of the of the children of
Manchester are being taken care of in
other ways this would allow a court to
say well okay I'm going to allow the
trust that established this to be change
the terms to be changed to something
that you know satisfies the the more
General intent of the person who made
the who made the donation that I think
that maybe is a bit of an
oversimplification but that's kind of
generally the idea thank you thank you I
when I was chair of Finance long time
ago I wanted to close YDC
because and because anyone who knew
no in recess or well yeah no we're no we
I
e
something we might want to consider when
we when we get around to executing the
is it is it the role of us the
government to tell people in private
litigation what their class action
settlements should be there if the
parties you know I just raised the
question maybe the answer is yes but I
just rais the
question
anyway
e
yeah maybe nobody's
here all
this Bank of Lights could be
my would you would you mind just
on I mean you do everything else for us
do you need the nurse or anything nurse
11:15 yeah yeah we're in we're in recess
my
e
on House Bill
um and I'm going to recognize uh chair
recognize representative kutab for uh to
introduce an uh an
amendment thank you chairman Len I'd
like to
move Amendment
2025 a move ought to pass on um with
Amendment 225 d016 7h and I second all
right
so now
going and the amendment is simply
lines
24 and
23 it's changing that with a victim less
than 18 years of age on both of those
lines rather than saying 16 years of age
or under or less than 16 and making
it two different two different numbers
there so less than 18 years of age
that's all the amendment is doing and I
the prosecutor was here uh attorney
in agreement that the amendment would
work right and I as I understand this
this this is a this is an amendment that
was jointly proposed by you and
representative tur is that correct that
is correct um and so um again my
recollection from our discussion of I
think it was last week was that this was
the only issue that you know sort of um
was was any that anyone had any any
problem with and otherwise it it
appeared that we were all generally
sympathetic to this bill with the
amendment um am I in am I incorrect in
that is anybody have any issue that um
you
know any reason that we shouldn't
execute now representative
Andrews I'm going to get back to the
same thing I'm going to vote no because
I think we need 20 people here to vote
committee 18 sorry about that all right
all right um all right uh I appreciate
your position representative Andrew but
I think I given the circumstances here I
disagree with it so um I guess I'm going
to first then call for a vote on the
amendment and I think we can do that by
a show of hands um so to ask all those
in in favor of amendment
11 did I count that right yes 11 okay
11 and all those opposed all right 11
to1 Amendment all right vote is 11 to1
in favor of
otpa and now on the
uh uh representative K I'm going to call
upon you again do you have a motion uh o
otpa on the main main motion yes I'm
move otpa on House Bill 369 with the
amendment we just passed right is there
a
second all right seconded by
representative
Smith all right all right anybody
anybody else have anything they want to
say uh before we vote on uh on the main
motion seeing none I would ask the clerk
to call the role on oot the motion is
otpa on House Bill 369 FN with Amendment
2025167529
representative Rambo yes representative
yes 11 Ys one
nay all right um so this will go on the
um yeah this is an early Bill yes so
this go on the regular calendar um
representative cutab could I ask you to
uh prepare the report I'd be happy to
and do you think you could do that by
tonight right I'll do it now oh got to
you it will there be a Minority Report
representative Andrews yeah all
all right just for your
information representative Manos has
signal that although she knows it
doesn't count the V she supports what
okay oh all right good all right um all
right so now I'm going to um
open the hearing on House Bill
FN and
x97 hang
on
uh uh let's see
um oh sure representative cab do you
want to introduce the bill if you would
please
thank you chairman Lynn and members of
the Judiciary Committee for the record
I'm representative Kaitlyn cab and I am
introducing House Bill 697 on behalf of
the Prime sponsor R Penza who couldn't
be here
today this bill allows witness fees for
criminal proceedings for civilian
Witnesses who appear in court to testify
and it is giving the same rate of fees
as those federally
authorized all right um any any
questions for this
witness see I I I I don't know whether
you're in the position to answer this
but can you I should know this but it's
been a long time since I was uh in
federal court so what what is the
1821 I think it's like 35
I think currently we have it as $35 and
we're in let me just check what I don't
want to give you inter give me one
second let me look and see what it is
now and what it would be going to just
so
I so we actually repealed that witness V
$40 per day $40 per day is the witness
fee and federal C correct okay all right
and
hours you you said I think where I
remember from last year that we had
repealed or I'm not sure if we did it
but it was there was no witness fee
stated is that is that
right it got repealed it used to be $12
it was repealed in
2019 okay all right anybody else have
any questions representative
Smith Oh representative buron you go
first then representative
Smith I just have one question when I
see the
word entitled to a payment does that
mean that that could just change on
constituents because it just says
payment it doesn't say an exact amount
that can be adjust adjusted when if in
the event that the cost is adjusted or
do you think we should just leave the
word it shall be entitled to a payment
and that's all it says it doesn't have
like
a I'm not sure where you're seeing
entitled to a payment oh entitled to a
payment for each day but it it gives the
rate the rate of the fee shall be the
same as those authorized in 28 USC
section one uh
1821 as the last sentence okay perfect
thank
you uh representative Smith thank you
um I'm
confused
um this seems to apply to when someone
has to come back again for reasons that
are no fault of their own what happens
when they're there the first time do
reimbursed think the answer is no
thank to my knowledge they do not and I
would be happy to pay them both times
but I think she was at least trying to
take a bite of the Apple particularly
for the cases that are really far away
people are taking time out of work and
driving sometimes quite a bit of a
distance to get there and not receiving
any payment and could I follow up of
course yes thank you and does that does
the fact that we don't reimburse the
first time explain why we are using not
a state rate but a federal rate because
we have no State
rate I believe that to be the case thank
you and the only other question I have
is should we be if if
we pass the bill the way it's worded
with that reference to the federal
statute um should there be any concern
should we have any concern that if the
feds which have not been known to
control spending very well decide that
they're going to increase the rate to
$100 a day or something like that that
then we will be on the hook to do the
same
thing well I should hope that with this
bill we will
make a much better effort to ensure that
we don't have witnesses driving in for
cases that are not then going to be
heard
because I I would hope that the reason
why we're having people come in should
be a pretty limited limited circumstance
and that we should know ahead of time
that there's been some extenuating
circumstance or whatnot so I'd hope that
we would just do a better job to to not
have this happen representative Smith
thank you um representative cutab what
would happen if in the fullness of time
um the federal government would decide
that will no longer uh uh pay uh witness
fees and uh would that then mean that we
would not be paying a fee that we think
is appropriate to pay I suppose that
could happen just as it could happen
that we reference with our in in the
State Rep statute for us to get Federal
mileage reimbursement that they could
come back and decide we're not going to
pay federal mileage anymore so I I think
it definitely it could happen
um hopefully it
doesn't representative
trip thank you for taking my question uh
you mentioned that uh uh you hop that uh
you wouldn't have people driving in to
uh
testify at a case and then not having
the case heard is that something that
happens
frequently I'm not sure of the exact
frequency but it definitely does happen
it happened in the case of the Prime
sponsor who put in the bill and I do
want to note that the federal rate was
Set uh in September of 1996 and has not
changed since so it's been about 29
same any other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you are there
any other witnesses that wish to appear
on House Bill 697 FN
seeing none um I would um be I guess
before I close the hearing just so that
we're still on the record you know one
one of things I would say in
representative cutab just on in my
experience and and uh representative
Manion may be able to shed some light on
this also I think it does
happen with some frequency that
Witnesses
are as as have to come back multiple
days because what often happen I mean I
mean I remember when I was when I was a
prosecutor we it often happened that I
that you know I would have more
witnesses than I needed for for the
particular day be there because if
somehow a witness took less time than I
thought and I ended up with no Witnesses
the judge was gonna was going to be
yelling at me why aren't you you know
why are we wasting all this time because
we know we're not finishing up today
because you don't have any Witnesses so
in order to once you've heard that a few
times and and frankly when I was a judge
I think I would probably have done the
same thing you you want you you've set
aside some time for trial you expect the
whatever you expect the sides to have
their witnesses there and since it's not
in any way an exact science what I think
what most good lawyers will do is make
sure that they they're not going to run
out of Witnesses on any particular day
which may mean that so you know they
have extra Witnesses and somebody has to
come back I I that that's that was my
experience I don't know about you uh
represented man
you yeah I agree with that um we didn't
have a lot of cases where there a lot of
witnesses that I prosecuted but yeah I I
you all right uh yes representative trip
since we're just making comments i' like
to comment that uh I was uh asked to be
a witness at it a a case one time and I
I drove from dairy to probably Portsmith
five times and the case was never
heard you so not getting paid for the
first time you know is a is an issue to
me thank you sure sure no I I hear you I
hear you um yeah I mean I I my own sense
I think generally I think this is the
bill is a is a good idea but you may be
right maybe we should you know maybe we
should be paying people should be paying
for the first time that you might be
right um well if the if the case isn't
heard does that mean it's not the first
time uh yeah I think that's I think
that's I mean especially if you've been
told to be there and then for at the
last minute the case isn't heard which
frequency all right well that's I mean
that's you know something for us to
consider when it's time to exec the bill
all right
um uh so now I'm going to close the
hearing on HB 696 FN and we actually
have time for
lunch must have I must have done
given this budget season I'd be fine
all right is everybody comfortable if we
exact
697 all right so um I so I'm going to
open the executive session and yeah yeah
yeah sure absolutely
absolutely take your time just let me
at oh K yeah that's
a is this still
on say
97 no it's it's not an it's not an early
Bill
no all right all right so
um uh HB 697 FN we I'm going to open the
executive session and um do I have a
motion with regard to House Bill 697 FN
FN all right um
all right um representative kab you wish
motion I just simply that I think if
we're requiring that a witness have to
be somewhere or subpoenaing them there
they should have some sort of
compensation for the time that they're
going to be out of work and for the
mileage that they're you know driving up
there I think it's only fair that if
we're requiring that we're taking up
their day their freedom for that day
that we should we should give them a
little bit of money in exchange for that
right anybody else wish to be heard on
uh
697 now I say as I I I think
representative Trip's point about um you
know maybe at some point in the future
we want to consider even for the first
time but as as you point out
representative katab given the current
budget situation maybe it's better to
get something for now and wait um and
and we don't want to let the perfect
become the enemy of the good so um
anybody else have anything they want to
say
all right so um I then asked the clerk
to call the role the motion is OTP on
House Bill 697 representative Manion yes
representative Alexander yes
representative trip
yes representative Andrew no
representative kutab yes clerk votes yes
representative
Smith representative Horgan yes
representative Paige yes
representative Rambo yes representative
Bergeron yes chairman Lynn
yes 11 Ys one
nay
um and
um reprentative couta can I call upon
you again would you mind making the
writing the report I'd be happy to
um then will there be a Minority Report
to representative Andrew I have a
question yes
where I'm doing no on the exact bills
yeah do I have to write a report for
each or should I for each bill that is
I'm not against the bill I'm just
against the process or can I do it all
on one I think you have to I think you
have to do it bill by Bill right I mean
mean but you could say one you could say
in
one if I could respond sure just because
you voted no does not mean that you have
to write a Minority Report there doesn't
have to be a Minority Report however if
you
are uh if you if you want to make clear
your reason is process and not the bill
itself you can do it
once and Bill no because I do not
believe that you can name
other bills in a Minority Report you can
only name the bill that you're writing
The Minority Report on so if you want to
make your point you can make it
once and then let it go but if you want
to make it three times you're going to
have to write three minority reports and
right right right this could go on
consent right if she doesn't want to
write a Minority Report this bill could
just go but the point that that I just
completely missed that is absolutely
true is you would have to have a
recommendation and if you don't want
your recommendation to be it can't be
the same as it can't be OTP in the case
um Louise may
I so you could you could in fact I guess
you could say
retain um which would be a different
position and which would indicate that
it should come back to the committee for
the committee to consider and your hope
would be that it would be with with more
people
present representative Andrews may I
suggest not not that I want to prolong
us at house session days but instead of
writing minority reports on all of those
bills maybe say something during
unanimous consent about how you voted
against these bills because you don't
agree with them with the process and
that might solve your problem where
you're able to make the statement but
you don't disagree with the committee
position yeah yeah that's fine okay sure
um yeah and she could do it as a
appropriately could do it as a floor
speech on the first of these bills and
then uh and I think at least imply that
she feels the same way about certain
other bills that are also going to be on
the reg the calendar yeah no that's
right yeah there's no sense of me
retaining a bill yeah I mean that's
crazy so if it excuse me if it's okay I
just won't write any reports and I'll
just make a statement on the house FL
okay so can we put this one on consent
we put this on consent then or no
because then she would go to the oh okay
no all right well I thought she's giving
a I thought she's giving unanimous
consent on all three bills at once no
she's not talking about unanimous
consent Kaitlyn she's talking about when
the bill
is Joe suggested unanimous consent yes
just give a flare speech and then don't
do any and then the voice bubly will be
so L what if only one of the bills goes
on a regular calendar
and you speak against it
explaining I mean you speak explaining
what your concerns are and that it
applies to other bills with the same
votes okay and then you can let the
other two go on consent that's fine with
me okay so
one you want the first one in numerical
order to go on the regular calendar the
first I think 36 9 had to go on the
regular calendar because it had not yes
it's an early bill right the other two
didn't like hp67 doesn't have
to which you have one is regular I'll
just write a
minority but then I got to go back to
ret no you don't have to write it
minority so if 369 goes on the
regular on the regular calendar right
okay you then would tell the
clerk that that you want to
speak on
369 and then six then
480 and
697 could just go on consent does that
people in terms of you making your point
and in terms of
efficiency yeah you know what you know
what for you know what I'm my only
concern representative Smith is even
though 480 is not listed as an early
bill that it wasn't listed because the
original bill was just talking about a
study committee but the amendment which
establishes that um the position of the
uh forensic liaison that will there is
there's going to need to be an
appropriation for that so that will
probably have to go to finance now so I
would say that we probably shouldn't put
that on consent except that bills that
are on consent can go to
finance oh they can I did not know that
okay all right then let's put that on
consent let's put 480 on consent and you
just want to make sure that both Paul
and
Ken Ken's still the chair knows about
that right okay clarification 480 is now
going on consent 480 is going on
consent sorry about that I'm sorry for
the confusion and the other two on the
regular Cal the other two on the regular
calendar yes and there and are no
minority reports at all there's there
there well well are we understanding
correctly uh representative Andress that
you will you will not be writing a
Minority Report but you will you will
let uh the clerk know that you desire to
speak um on whichever of these bills
comes up first uh to express your view
on the procedure yeah no that's fine
because to do a Minority Report I got to
put it what retain it or
consent yeah I thought HP 697 was also
on
consent right all right so hang on so
here's what I have
369 will cannot be on consent because
it's going to finance and it's listed as
an early Bill
480 even though it will end it's not an
early bill now even though it will end
up going to finance
um I'm I'm advised by representative
Smith and I have no reason to doubt is
that we can put it on consent so we will
and then the last bill
on
consent and two for consent and two for
consent
and no reports by right
okay all right good well this I i' I'm
pleased with you know having been able
to EXA three bills that's that's good
all right so let's um let's go get
something to eat and uh we'll be back at
1:00 so I'm going to recess the uh the
all
e
you know in in right-wing media like the
Wall Street Journal or you know slate
and Salon left-wing media uh stories of
people who got their bachelor's their
Master MERS maybe an additional degree
um and you know were following all along
exactly what they were told by their
middle school guidance counselors their
high school guidance counselors their
parents uh the media you know the
presidents getting up and saying uh you
know this nation you know needs to get
education education is the way to the
middle class and the upper middle class
and the um lenders are there and very
eager to make all of uh you know these
outlays to the students oh you want a
you know a master's degree in foreign
affairs uh undergrad in political
science you know here is the check just
sign here what a lot of 17 and 18 year
olds uh and and that speaks by the way
to the asymmetric negotiating position
what a lot of very naive 17 and 18 year
olds don't understand is that student
loans are non-dischargeable and uh that
is something the federal government has
chosen to do to make sure that lenders
are there if uh student loans were
dischargeable in bankruptcy you would
see 29y olds with $300,000 in debt and
effectively no uh tenable career path
ahead of them because you know they're
in a career field that maybe is uh uh
pleasing to them but pays $30,000 a year
they will never ever ever be able to pay
off these loans and then the federal
government and their wisdom has also
said that you cannot Escape these loans
even by declaring bankruptcy you can
declare bankruptcy you can wash away
your $20,000 in credit card your 5,000
car loan but you still have this 300
$400,000 of student loan hanging over
your head and a lot of the limits that
you see from people are I will never be
able to afford to get married I will
never be able to buy a house so I'll
never do this I'll never do that um and
obviously I'm a registered Republican
there is a lot of um uh rhetoric on my
side of the aisle um you know not in the
uh general court but you know in the
populace as a whole you know haha well
that'll teach you to get a degree in
underwater basket weaving you know as
the joke goes and um you know it's and
in fact not really funny these are
people who made these decisions when
they were very young they followed all
of the best advice that was given to
them and they are in an entirely
untenable life
path now a lot of degrees are in fact
useful um you know nursing degrees stem
degrees um even you know other uh
degrees are tenable for certain people
if you are uh you know a child of the
wealthy you can go off and you can get a
history degree you can follow it up with
a history PhD you can have a great
career because you've got your um you
know family wealth waiting there for you
but for a lot of other people who don't
understand that you know they've sort of
walked into a Porsche dealership and
they're being offered these luxury goods
that are being sold under the premise
that these are investments uh it is a
very bad situation so that brings us to
the actual bill before us right now this
bill defines certain um Educational
Services as sort of inherently
fraudulent or deceptive and so you know
let's get into that is is this a
subjective decision should there be
someone who said well you know I got an
engineering degree so it's you know if
you majored in social work that's
inherently deceptive you know no that
that is the wrong approach to take to
this and there are a lot of uh degrees
that at a certain price point are quite
reasonable uh someone can you know if
you can get a history degree for you
know $25,000 $30,000 that's reasonable
the problem is if people are being given
these degrees that will never pay for
themselves so uh there is uh some math
in here but I'd like to walk through the
math what do I mean by will never pay
for itself if someone graduates with a
degree and gets an average job in their
industry and then they take 30% of their
take-home pay which is quite a lot you
know I remember being a 21y old and
paying you know half my salary just for
an apartment um 30% of your salary every
month for 10 years if that can't pay off
your degree then you are uh effectively
in a debt trap you know if 30% for 10
years can't get you out what possibly
could get you out out now we talked
before about if you were in a certain
situation you know maybe you were the
you know a Rockefeller Scion and you
absolutely know that your passion is to
you know study Byzantine history uh and
you don't need to have some high-paying
career at the end that is ever going to
pay for this this uh bill has a way that
any student can just sign a waiver
saying I understand that this
educational degree that you're selling
me is not conventionally uh going to
result in a conventionally remunerative
career
there is also the issue that a lot of
colleges um offer degrees that are seen
as very prestigious especially in Asia
so a lot of colleges make a lot of money
by selling uh degree programs to foreign
students this bill does not extend
protections to those foreign students
someone coming from mainland China um
and paying for an American degree has
probably uh you know got the means to do
so and it is not New Hampshire's
business to uh meddle in their decision
nor in the University's business model
of selling very expensive degrees to
Chinese or other people um so that is an
overview of the bill and then finally
this provides two kinds of action one is
the attorney general if uh that office
ever desires to do anything could
prosecute um a university for offering a
fraudulent uh service but there is
nothing in this bill that requires them
to do so um if you look at the rest of
the consumer protection act there are
other things where the attorney general
has the authority they can go after a
store for offering going out of business
sales every 60 days they can go after a
car dealer for you know offering certain
services but there's nothing that forces
the AG's office to do that um so there's
nothing here that compels the AG's
office to do anything uh finally one
question that came up in the drafting
with OS discussions was how would a
student prove this um you know is there
a set uh criteria there are in fact uh
lots of surveys uh showing um what
people in various career Fields earn
universities themselves often gather
this information internally and maintain
it but it is not the job of the bill to
make anyone else's case for them um
there are many cases in the law that
give citizens a right of private action
and if a citizen you know has the right
to sue a neighbor for runoff it is the
Citizen's job to go out and get a
structural engineer or a groundwater
engineer and prove their case and go to
court and uh this bill uh has that same
uh standard uh it does not uh do the
citizens job for them I'm open any
questions please questions for this
witness yes representative
pner thank you Mr chair and thank you
representative corkren for being here I
was smiling only because um your your uh
s your um analogies were amusing not
that over this situation so I have a
question about um the Attorney General
Prosecuting so for example if we have
the university system of New Hampshire
which is a public colle College we would
have a situation where the state could
possibly be prosecuting the state in
this situation and then and then after
um so what would you suggest in that
situation or would you um address this
specifically to private colleges uh uh I
think that's a great question and in the
same way that the AG if they choose to
weighing all of the merits of the case
weighing you know uh uh the pros and
cons um of sort of you know political
situation other thing for example
chooses to uh go after a DCF employee or
a state police employee um you know the
attorney general you know in their
wisdom can decide when something is
egregious enough now uh let me raise
another Point uh also in response to
this that this need not be seen as sort
of purely punitive and after the fact if
a bill like this existed and if either a
private college or a state college was
tempted to offer a new eight-year degree
in throwing ceramics at the wheel uh
they would have to ask hey is this
likely uh going to put us in danger with
this law and that incentive structure um
is part of it so it's not just after the
fact what the AG might do yes followup
it's I'm sorry it's not technically a
follow-up but have you ever seen or
heard of situations in which the
parents um complete the FAFSA and take
on student debt that's not the student
doesn't necessarily know that this is
happening because they're 17 years old
maybe when they're applying for college
parents fill out the application and
agree to take on the debt and the I have
sorry if I haven't if it's in here
somewhere and then the student finds out
upon graduation that now they're saddled
with this what's their recourse against
their own parents right um so I I I am
aware of that I think that is a tragic
situation um and in this case I believe
that the wording here where the parents
sort of you know effectively make the
decision but offload the debt it would
be the student again uh the metric is
their salary um and so they would have
recourse um and again you know I I would
be thrilled if this will Bill were to
pass and become law if there was never a
single lawsuit under this bill but if
instead universities said you know hey
wait a second we've been offering uh
this one degree and a certain thing that
no one ever gets employment in or the
employment is $30,000 perhaps we should
you know merge that with another degree
or change the requirements uh for it so
that it becomes more lucrative um so uh
yes I I I think that's a great concern
and that also speaks to what I was
introducing it as where you've got 17
and 18year olds who are very naive uh
have a very rose tinted glass uh view of
the world and can get themselves in a
world of trouble and uh you know it's
one thing for an adult to make a
decision you know I'm going to rent that
Porsche I deserve it and then you know
after six years of payments I really
screwed up uh it's another thing when a
17-year-old signs on the dotted line and
at 45 years old says I wish wish I could
afford a house
someday other questions representative
Smith um thank you um so am I correct
that you see this bill as an effort at
consumer protection 100% correct thank
you uh could I follow up yes of course
would you change your position at all
you you began by uh making clear what
political iCal party you belong to which
I hadn't seen was relevant but perhaps
it is relevant since on the national
level it appears that the national
government the federal government um is
um
uh challenging the existence of the
entire consumer protection effort would
that change your position on this bill
um so let me first say that the reason I
introduced my own party was to say that
I think that to some degree I'm arguing
against interest as a lawyer would say
which is you would expect in general it
would be people on the left who tend to
speak in favor of student loan
forgiveness and I just wanted to say
that you know uh I'm a person you know
who doesn't necessarily share all of
those cultural political Norms but still
understand the sort of financial tragedy
that many people are in um and speaking
to uh changes at a federal level um you
know obviously none of us in this room
have any power at that level but the
great thing about the Federal syst
system is that there's the sort of you
know the 50 Laboratories of democracy
and we can make our own rules here and
uh you know we're uh this bill to pass
and were it to have both sort of
retroactive applicability where you know
someone having already gotten a
deceptively advertised degree gets
Justice and in the future where because
we said incentives future people are
spared that danger um I would think that
this could be something that could
perhaps be replicated in other states so
if you were worried that you know the
country is heading in a certain
direction and might not be heading back
for decades to come uh that these states
can do a lot to achieve Justice for
young
people and if could I just ask one could
you show me where in the bill and maybe
I just haven't read it carefully enough
it says that it would be
retroactive um as soon as that word came
out of my mouth I was immediately uh
upset with my word choice um I I did not
intend to have that in there thank
you other questions this
witness so I guess I do have a question
isn't even without this isn't the
consume I mean if if there really has
been an institution that
has um you know misrepresented the value
of its educational programs isn't that
covered already under the consumer
protection act thank you for the
question um I believe it's not um and
part of that is because what exactly do
you mean by by misrepresentation and
this again gets to power dynamics um you
know if a university said sign up for
our anthropology degree we guarantee you
that this degree will pay for itself and
it will be guaranteed entrance to the
middle class where the middle class is
defined as this income to that income uh
then a student would you know have a
very strong case um but you know having
gone through college myself at all times
there's this you know welcome to a brand
new world this is your pathway way to
the future I mean Pathway to the future
is the kind of language that's used all
the time and you can't you know go to
court and say but your honor the dean of
students said it was the pathway to the
Future well you know it's now the year
2029 congrats you're in the future um so
uh you know there has never been to my
understanding any sort of case against
uh universities um under existing law
and yet universities under existing law
continuously offer degrees that end up
costing hundreds of thousands of dollars
and can never pay for
themselves other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you very much for your time
next I'm going to call on Lauren Banker
please
good afternoon Mr chair members of the
committee um for the record my name is
Lauren Banker I serve as the Director of
government relations for the University
uh system of New Hampshire we are here
today in opposition to House Bill
722 I just wanted to provide a few
points
um and then uh I'll say this is not an
area that I have a lot of expertise in
so if I can do some followup with my
colleagues back at our campuses I'm
happy to do so uh I'll start by saying
that affordability and accessibility are
core values of our institutions and that
we take great pride in providing
opportunity to each of our students and
equipping them with the experiences
Knowledge and Skills to thrive in their
career um but we while we appreciate the
sponsor's goal uh we have several major
concerns with the proposed legislation
uh I I'll hit on two things and then um
you know the backside of uh my testimony
has a a little bit more as well uh the
first being that the bill would require
detailed earnings data for graduated
students by degree program to determine
the average annualized four-year pre-tax
inflation adjusted salary of grads of uh
each of the degree programs we do not um
and could not capture this sort of
detailed earnings data for each of our
graduates and that this
uh requisite level and completeness of
earnings data is um information that
would only be available through the um
IRS we are currently working diligently
to comply with recently enacted uh
Federal Regulations with regards to
financial value transparency and gainful
employment all of our institutions have
recently I think as of January 15th
submitted uh record level student data
that will be matched with national
student loan and IRS earnings data and
this data is going to be analyzed and
post Ed to a publicly facing website in
order to provide students and families
with a clear um comparable information
about financial outcomes of educational
programs um so above all you know this
this work is being done on the federal
level um that we are uh following all
the regulations and Reporting
requirements we've been investing um
hundreds of hours to collect review
analyze securely transmit Ure the
accuracy of this data um as required by
the federal legislation so ultimately
this bill seeks is seeking to create a
duplicative process and create
additional and unnecessary
administrative and financial burden on
our institutions at a time where we're
already facing significant financial
constraints I'm happy to answer any
questions um the committee thank you
questions yes representative Oregon and
then representative um thank you very
much isn't um is it fair to say that one
extenda circumstance especially for
major universities like un each is that
they rely heavily on alumni donations so
you do have an interest in making sure
your alumni um earned earn enough money
not just to pay off their loans but even
have something left over for other
things in life including uh including
donating to their Alam mat yeah as an
Alum of unh I definitely have that
Affinity yeah thank you representative
Smith thank you very much
um I'm been I'm interested in this bill
and I'm I'm not sure
were kind of Who's on First in terms of
whether it's the University or whether
it's a
lender not a grantor But A lender or
whatever um so it's a little confusing
to me but can you tell me when um a
student
applies uh for
whatever particular academic Pursuit um
are they given um either a guarantee or
a statement by the uh educational
institution that if they enter such such
a degree program they will be
guaranteed a
certain um income as a
result I don't know specifically what
each of the campuses are doing with that
regard but I'm happy to follow up with
our career offices and see I know
there's been a lot of investment in
energy and sour into our career and
professional success uh offices at each
of our campuses um so I know that this
is something that they um value and I
can I'm happy to follow up could I
repeat that question
sure do you really mean to tell
me that it's a possibility or a
probability that
any
employee of a
university will guarantee to to an
applicant what their income will be if
they pursue a particular
degree I don't I don't know I don't
think so but I don't know thank you very
much other questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you next I'm going to call on uh
thank you Mr chairperson members of the
committee my name is Brandon Gad I am a
senior Assistant Attorney General I am
also the chief of the consumer
protection and any trust Bureau at the
New Hampshire Department of Justice I am
here before you neither in support nor
opposed to this bill I think that you
know the merits behind this bill and the
the cost of an education are a concern
that is shared pretty much across the
board by everybody
um but as the chief of the consumer
protection anti trust Bureau that will
be responsible for enforcing the
provisions of the statute um I think
that it's important that when
considering this legislation that this
committee U think about two important
issues um one is enforceability and the
other is practically the resources that
it would take to implement what this um
bill anticipates I'll start by noting
that I do see that a request for a
fiscal note was made and I apologize
that we did not provide one um as the
consumer Chief all of the consumer
protection related fiscal notes are
usually sent to me I did not see this
one um this must have fallen through the
cracks um so apologies for that but I
think I can provide the information that
would have been contained in a fiscal
note to the committee
today um I don't often appear before
this committee usually the consumer
protection bills are in House Commerce
so I thought it might be helpful to just
give a general sense of If This Were
enacted um how our consumer Protection
Bureau gets information gets complaints
and you know decides on investigative
and enforcement priorities we have a
consumer protection hotline that is open
5 days a week it is manned by volunteers
anybody can call in and speak to a real
person who believes they are have an
issue that you know may be a violation
of the consumer protection act or may be
something that any member of the
Department of Justice might be able to
help with um the majority of those folks
who identify plausible consumer
protection violations are steered
towards fing a Consumer complaint in
writing with the bureau I review every
one of those complaints and for those
complaints that have any semblance of
Merit um based on a possible violation
of our statute we send them to the
business and we ask the business to
respond in writing many businesses do um
and many businesses resolve those
complaints by responding in that way um
for the ones that don't or the ones that
don't in a satisfactory way um we have
the discretion to open a larger
investigation issue subpoenas talk to
Witnesses and if we build a case that an
unfair deceptive actor practice exists
and has been committed we have the
ability to pursue both criminal charges
if appropriate or to bring a civil
enforcement action to enjoin the conduct
and seek fines and restitution against
the offending business so you know I I
think that's important context to
understand because the you know the
sponsor is not wrong to say that this
does not require the Attorney General
office to do anything under this bill
but anytime you're adding to the
consumer protection act which is
enforced certain parts of it are
enforced exclusively by the Consumer
Protection Bureau of the Attorney
General's office it creates a perfectly
Fair expectation amongst consumers in
the states that if they are the victim
and have been wronged by unfair
deceptive actor practice that they can
turn to the Attorney General's office
who will take their complaint seriously
investigate it and if appropriate bring
an enforcement action so you know that
discretion of whether or not to proceed
exists across the board um but anytime a
bill is passed that entrusts us to
enforce any new provision of consumer
rights in the state we want to make sure
that it's passed in a way where we can
actually do it if there are complaints
and if there are violations that we can
provide meaningful enforcement of that
statute otherwise it's mostly just for
show uh and I think there are real
problems here and the the first part of
it comes with you know I think that you
know some of the comments that were
submitted by the university system of
New Hampshire there's significant
resources that would be needed at a
minimum just to allow the universities
themselves to be able to compile the
data that we could then you know either
subpena or request and review in order
to determine whether or not the the
amount being charged is in excess or in
line with the threshold that's created
by the statute so unless those resources
are allocated and the universities are
able to meaningfully put this data
together we would be left to either um
do that work ourselves which we are not
in a position to do or to be left unable
to enforce the statute because we
wouldn't be able to determine um whether
or not the you know average tuition as
anticipated by the statute is or is not
in excess of the threshold that was
created um if those resources were
allocated such that the universities
could provide those numbers it would
still require significant additional
resources at the Attorney General's
office to meaningfully enforce the
statute um the consumer protection and
antitrust Bureau is enforced with
enforcing all of the consumer protection
and antitrust statutes in the state
which was recently expanded to include
um data privacy we're also tasked with
um registering all the health clubs in
the state all the Condominiums land
sales um enforcing the state's tobacco
uh related statutes and investigating
and Prosecuting the most serious cases
of finan uh Elder Financial abuse and
exploitation just to name a few and we
regularly hit above our weight in terms
of the resources that we have and all
the things that we are expected to do
think we do the best with what we can
and we get meaningful results for
consumers but this would be a
significant expansion um that would
create a 10year right for every single
graduate in the state to file a
complaint um with the AG's office and it
just review those complaints and
meaningfully investigating issuing
subpoenas reviewing the documents that
would come in response to those
subpoenas doing a meaningful calculus to
determine whether or not the tuition
being charged is or is not in excess of
the threshold anticipated by the statute
would require additional resources
probably in the realm of three
additional employees in order to
meaningfully do this um in the way that
is anticipated by this
statute um I think the chairperson asked
a good question earlier which was you
know is this already covered and I I
think that it is to the extent that any
University is making any sort of claims
about what income you will receive or
can expect to receive unless it is is
firmly supported by statistics that they
can support and guarantee for you know
those folks that are enrolling in their
program there's obviously a number of
variables uh including you know how
successful the student is in their
coursework what you know jobs they
ultimately pursue what internships they
pursue um that determine you know the
amount of income that that people can
get so I think because of that
universities more likely than not are
very unlikely to make those sorts of
representations but it has happened in
the past um the there were several four
profit colleges including IT Tech um
that were making those types of
representations to students essentially
guaranteeing a certain level of income
if they were to complete their programs
and those um colleges were jointly
investigated by uh the New Hampshire
Attorney General's office as well as the
majority of the Attorney General's
offices across the country um and were
offer and were required to pay
significant fines and stop their
practices so to the extent specific
representations about the amount that
you can expect to earn are being made
are not true um that would be an unfair
and deceptive actor practice under our
existing statute even though it's not a
specifically delineated unfair and
deceptive actor practice so I I think
that's all the testimony that I have
today I'm happy to take questions if
there are any question representative
Horgan and um see do you and do you feel
what do you feel about the fact that
um universities don't really have the
well they don't really have the capacity
to control what Life Choices they uh
their graduates make after you know
after they get out of school and also um
so people often make Life Choices you
know they may get a degree for a
high-paying uh job and then decide some
other type of work interest them that
applies for example to all of us around
the table we're making $100 a year as a
State Rep but um and also what about
things that are not voluntary people
like sometimes you know some people
unfortunately then acquire chronic
illnesses and they can't do the high
paying job they were trained for and
there's all kinds of other circumstances
so well what sort difficulties you think
the bill poses in that regard that
they're ask universities to be liable
for for things that aren't under their
control so without getting at the merits
of the bill I do think that the issues
you've raised highlight some of the
difficulties that we would have in
enforcement um all of that would need to
be considered and all of that would need
to be calculated in order to
meaningfully determine whether or not a
college or a university was in violation
of the statute so I I think that you
know th those are certainly concerns and
they they go right to I believe our
ability to meaningfully enforce this and
gather all the data that would be
necessary to truly determine whether or
not tuition is excessive or not or
unreasonable or not under this
statute other questions for this
witness seeing wh I'm sorry
representative B thank you Mr chair and
I do appreciate in advance I was curious
because I
know five years ago when Betsy DeVos was
actually in DC I was um for the
Department of Education I was really
curious because I know that there were a
lot
of colleges capella people like that
that were
actually making a few offers that they
probably shouldn't but I just know that
that was s supported from the Department
of Education at the time so I guess do
you see any of kind of like that
involving with this at all I could you
be more specific as to what you're
referring to it's like GI bills things
like that where colleges took advantage
of you know the the uh education funds
that vets
have I'm not sure how much overlap there
would be there this is strictly about
the cost of tuition for a specific um
degree program
so I suppose that could impact it one
way or another I mean there were there
are a number of factors that could
influence the both the you know price
that a university charges but then
ultimately what the average salary based
on all the graduates combined using all
the factors under the statute what that
number actually is and comparing the two
numbers I think that's that's the
difficulty that I think we would face in
enforcing this in a meaningful
way yeah because that wasn't
fun thank you other
questions seeing none thank you very
much sir thank you
all is there anyone else who wishes to
testify on House Bill 722
FN seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing on 7:22 FN and we're a little
bit early so I'll hang on before we uh
oh
that's
yeah
okay
69 wa hang on oh
yeah
okay
e
7 it's now
1:45 um and I'm going to open the
hearing on uh House Bill
um is there anybody
here that
uh that wants to
uh appear on that bill I don't see
anybody um could I representative burron
could I call on you just to uh introduce
the bill you don't all you have to say
is uh just go to the thing and say
you're introducing it and that'll be
all thank you it's getting good yeah
thank you very
thank you Mr
chair uh I would like to start out and
talk
about 746 yep 746
FM relative to an award of attorney's
fee upon a successful appeal of a local
property ATT uh assessment thank you
very much any
questions all right so um is there
anyone uh who wishes to
appear um in support
of HB 746 anyone else who wishes to
testify U seeing none I'm going to close
the hearing on House Bill
um all right
uh I wish I wish we actually had had
somebody I mean I think and as a general
matter it may not be a bad idea but I do
have a couple of questions about details
at any rate
um maybe when we schedule an exec
session somebody will appear for
that
so um so we have some time on our hands
um oh I'm sorry I will close the I think
I did but if I didn't I'll close the
um yeah I know I don't I'm not sure
there really is anything else
because we don't have enough yeah we
don't even have enough people add one
two eight yeah you're right only eight
people only eight
I
use oh you know I
um representative Kaba I'm gonna go talk
to Karen right now to
you
e
now 2:30 and I'm going to uh open the
hearing on House Bill 762
fnaa and I will uh recognized
representative representative Linda
Hoskins the uh Prime uh I'm sorry a
sponsor good afternoon thank you Mr
chair and members of the
committee uh for the record I am
representative Linda H Haskins from
exitor Rockingham 11 I'm here to
introduce
762 on behalf of Representative Zoe
Manos who's ill today I am also a
co-sponsor of this bill
the purpose of the bill is to enable the
judicial branch to hire an independent
contractor to conduct a manual review of
domestic violence stalking cases and
related criminal cases to compile and
collate data for statistical analysis by
the judicial
branch it authorizes an appropriation of
$30,000 to do this
without proper data it is impossible to
determine where and what resources are
needed in domestic violence in stalking
cases and related criminal cases within
branch right now the judicial branch
only keeps records in domestic violence
and stalking cases on paper in paper
files there is no electronic filing in
these cases and no coordination with
related criminal
cases is very
limited the circuit courts cannot see
data across the cases or the country or
Statewide in order to determine and
evaluate what resources are necessary
the first step is to gather data and
that means manually reviewing the paper
case files to gather the data this bill
will enable the judicial branch to hire
an independent contractor to do this
it's important to emphasize that no
personal
information that identifies any party
will be gathered or
recorded the data is used for
statistical analysis
only the bill recognizes that the
judicial branch may be able to secure
funding from other
sources if so those funds would be
applied prior to this
appropriation it is critically important
that we collect this data it will enable
us to determine what additional
resources are needed by the judicial
branch in domestic violence and stocking
cases
and related criminal cases it will also
enable us to determine what additional
resources are needed to support victims
and what resources are needed to allow
perpetrators to address their
violence attorney Aaron KGAN who is
General Counsel to the administrative
office of the
courts I believe is represented here
today to testify as well
Pamela keig who is the public policy
specialist for the New Hampshire
Coalition against Domestic and Sexual
Violence was not able to stay but you
have her information her testimony and
she would welcome contact from the
committee any questions or information
want I am not prepared to answer
questions there are others who are more
knowledgeable than I so I would um refer
to those folks for questions and I have
a caucus so I'm not able to stay but it
is a pleasure to see you all and to
introduce Zoe's bill it's a very
important one thank you thank you all
right um next um I'm going to recognize
please push the button thank you good
afternoon
Representatives uh my name is Anthony
Kenny I'm from Middleton uh New
Hampshire um I'm here to oppose this
bill um in in just a few short uh
words um
just give me one second here I don't
know why this is not
working my notes anyways um I have a
family case um 630 2020 dm42 that's my
family case um it relates to uh a
criminal case where where my ex had
assaulted me and was criminally arrested
in 2017 that's 4 uh 64 2017 CR 430 uh
where she was arrested for simple
assault criminal uh charges uh were
brought up and we had those dismissed
and then we started our family case in
2020 and in
2022 she got a bogus DV stating that uh
uh the 2017 incident was me hitting her
even though it's documented uh that's
case number 630 2022
dv21 uh and and after watching um
witnessing my son get assaulted and
attacked on numerous occasions called
for welfare
checks um and I reached out to the
firstes line of communication between a
parent and their child as the other
parent I was inheld criminally on
several charges so you know sir I I I
guess I'm I'm I'm really trying to under
you know what is all the the details of
some particular case have to do with
this well I disagree with this bill
especially if it's not going to
pronounce names to spend $30,000 when
when Gordon McDonald had just said that
you know there's not enough money for a
trial okay so these three criminal cases
two of them were simply calling the
police department for a welfare check
they held me for third party
communication 60 days without bail and
when I asked for a denovo hearing in
front of a
jury they were told me that I would have
to remain in preventative detention and
told that trial these were bogus cases
all related to family court all related
to DV uh domestic violence where she was
the one assaulted me and then later on
even though I had evidence at the
hearing the judge didn't want to see it
and I was then
held uh they gave a final DV order in
the family case where there was already
problems communicating and when I
reached out to protect my own son I was
then arrested and held without bail and
when I when I was tried maliciously
tried and asked for denovo hearing at
Superior Court they gave me a new bail
hearing the circuit court and said that
if I wanted to have a jury
trial then I would have to remain this
was the day of my release I had already
served my sentence I would have to
remain
incarcerated unless I
withdraw so I don't understand why you
would want to spend
$330,000 on anybody investigating
especially if you guys have the power to
subpoena and possibly impeach any of
those Bad actors that have kept my son
In Harm's Way for five years when I I
was retaliated against through the
family court it was the same judge in
her criminal case in 2017 the same judge
in the DV case and the same judge in all
three criminal cases that were all
brought on on allegations alone I don't
understand why you want anybody to
investigate you can investigate my case
I'll give you this paper you can
investigate the case with Joe Nan
Stephanie Turon Lind Smith Destiny
Bernard Harmony Harmony Montgomery
rugerio and rerio you must know that
case Matthew McDonald all family cases
all domestic violence been related all
criminal and all
hogwash so there's plenty right here on
this one page for this body if you want
it you don't have to investigate you
don't have to go far we we can just we
can just decide to impeach those judges
no what I'm saying is there's plenty to
investigate right here without spending
$30,000
all you have to do is pull up these case
numbers okay there's plenty it's all
related to this bill without spending
$30,000 which we could put back into
let's have two more weeks of jury trial
let's keep that jury going there's no
reason that this body or the
representatives or the Democrats or
wherever the money's coming from should
have to spend that money if there's
already enough and and I could go on I
could I could give you all these
dockhead numbers before you leave here
today and I could give you a list of 30
more people there's no reason to dig in
with $30,000 to at you know starting at
scratch okay all right any questions
please questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you next I'm going to call on
please good good afternoon Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
by name is Dana alre uh nashio New
Hampshire uh and you should have three
handouts uh one is an uh just a summary
of an email I sent everyone this morning
it has a large number of
attachments uh no need to kill trees but
you've got a complete record there uh
electronically of the current
proceedings that the judicial branch is
done under Justice
Marone uh to address domestic violence
so there was a lot of Prior work on this
by Justice
Marone uh you've got uh in terms of uh
budgeting the uh presentation by the
Chief Justice to the uh Joint Committee
of Judiciary and children and family law
uh so that's all pretty relevant to
budgeting on this and uh you've also got
one federal court case that I think is
relevant
uh uh
just excuse me uh I'll find it when I
come back to it uh it's Kell ve New
Hampshire in District Federal District
Court New
Hampshire
um so uh when I kind of tried to figure
out what's going on in these cases the
judicial branch I requested training
materials uh that's one of the handouts
and apparently this is a huge deal
because General counil KGAN said that uh
in June of 2023 domestic violence con
topics constituted the bulk of the
training for Circuit Court judges with
three full days devoted to the topics
for recently appointed judges and a full
day for other judges so we seem to be
spending a whole lot of money on this
with extremely little transparency
on how it's actually being spent how
these judges are actually being
trained and uh that's particularly
concerning you know when other
jurisdictions like over in the fifth
circuit uh the federal appell at court
there is made very clear that these
kinds of orders are essentially uh
granted to whoever shows up to court
uh thank you um we already know that um
they're granted against people like
David lutman because somebody was afraid
of them on TV we know that uh they're
granted whoever goes down to court first
the fifth circuit specifically
referenced training materials in its
opinion and that these training
materials are the problem and if you
know this body or we the people can't
even see these train materials why
should we be throwing
$30,000
um uh none of these re Lindsay Smith
who's the domestic violent shooting
victim who was brutally shot after
paully Hall denied a restraining order
hasn't gotten a single penny from the
state maybe she deserves some resources
and not the judicial branch um maybe we
should devote resources towards jury
trials
um Miss Smith's closest one of her
closest friends Miss Destiny barard was
also incarcerated in preventative
detention for three days no right to a
jury trial no access to
counsel um you know once again because
of this phenomena of whoever goes down
to court first in this so-called civil
proceeding automatically gets the order
so the statute itself 173b is it's an
Unholy am allegation of civil and
criminal law where the respondent uh is
subject to all the penalties of the
criminal justice system and has none of
the rights normally afforded criminal
def defendants in the criminal justice
system there's a de facto
practice uh where the plaintiff in the
so-called alleged civil 173b cases uh is
essentially presumed to be correct
uh unless the uh responded again in a
soall civil case after the fact uh
manages to prove Beyond a reasonable
doubt they're innocent this is a
complete reversal of traditional
American jurist
Prudence uh you're putting domestic
violent victims in jail now in
preventative detention solely because
their abusers were the ones who went to
court first
and you want to spend 3,00 $30,000 to
study more of the same when you know
Justice Marone has already been all over
it with 10 meetings we've got 15
meetings at the governor's commission
and nothing's come with that so I really
question what we hope to get for this
$330,000 when is you know Mr Kenny the
prior speaker said so many people have
shown up to testify and can give you all
the problem docket so I would propose we
uh either itl this or we replace it with
some kind of investigatory study
committee in the legislature to really
address you know the constitutionality
of
173b you know otherwise like the federal
court opinion passed out you know right
now we have people starting to challenge
you know those statutes in federal court
and I would only anticipate that's going
to continue as we go further and further
downhill putting innocent people in jail
in preventative detention with no right
to a jury trial just because they're Dev
victims and their abusers made it to
court first with that said I'll take
questions questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
sir thank you next I'll call on Aaron
good afternoon afternoon Erin krian
general counsel for the judicial branch
um just coming to discuss this bill
which I really appreciated that um
representative Manos reached out to us
and and had a general question what was
the best way to get answers to specific
factual questions and I think she's
still working with stakeholders on what
she wants those questions to be that
would be fact dependent in order to show
how common or uncommon certain factual
characteristics are in DB cases um I
haven't seen that list from her I know
she's working on it but we we had a
chance to engage with her about
potentially the best way to do that
which is because over 95% of these cases
are in paper they it it typically
involves a human going and looking
through the paper for certain
characteristics um so for example I
think she had said something at one
point to me about how many children
under a certain age involved we would
have to review that manually from the
record uh so that's that I think this is
the correct way to to do that if it is
what the legislature would like to do
and I appreciate her collaboration and
work to kind of do it in a way that was
something that we could action it is
absolutely up to the legislature whether
to appropriate this money for this
purpose but um I do know that this is a
source of enduring questions that we
have people want to learn more about the
features of different DB cases so I do
think there is a demand um should it be
your desire to fund it uh but I'm I'm
not aware that there is any other way
besides an actual manual review of the
paper that we could get the level of
detail that people have been seeking of
cases right great questions for this yes
representative
trip uh thank you for taking my question
I I know you're not the uh sponsor of
the bill but you seem to have been
involved in uh the writing of it and uh
I'm uh I'm interested in
uh what the use of the uh or who's going
to be using this data because it it
talks about the the judicial B judicial
branch governance Commission on domestic
violence sexual assault stalking and
other interested individuals or persons
you know uh do you have any idea who the
other interested persons might be I
don't but I suspect it would be those
that are involved in the space so
thought leaders people who work at
nonprofits people who are maybe
Affiliated in a loose way with the
Coalition on domestic violence um I
would expect that it would be folks that
typically appear at meetings on this
subject
um so I I would uh assume that the data
that's collected during this time would
be uh published
somewhere my expectation is that we
would publish it in a report that would
be available on the website because this
would be statistical data how often um
are young children involved how often
are certain facts present it would not
reveal any individual person's private
information uh so it would be answering
questions that that people sometimes
have about how common certain factual
characteristics are in DV
cases yep go ahead one more uh do you
have any idea of how many years this
review would cover I believe that that
was intentionally left vague because of
we don't have the questions so if we
receive a very large set of questions
$30,000 may only go back a few years if
we receive a small set of questions we
may be able to go relatively far back in
years uh so I think that that was not uh
specifically said because we don't have
the questions yet yet thank you other
questions for this witness yes
representative
pno in this modern day and age where we
have all of our data on electronic
devices why are these all only on paper
it's a great question um not so long ago
almost all case types were uh paper case
types and it it is a cost of over
$100,000 to transition a case type so we
have been slowly over time transitioning
case types from paper to electronic over
over a decade and many of them are now
electronic uh but there are a few that
are not the reason that this one hangs
around on the list is is a few fold one
if we did make it uh digital it would
probably need to be handled a little bit
different so it would need to have
certain features that you would expect
to see for DV cases like an escape
button the person can press which will
normalize their screen so that if their
users right behind them they they don't
see that they were working on a petition
um so the bidding is a little bit higher
for that so and we just haven't had the
extra funds to transition this case type
it is something that will happen
eventually other questions so Mr I guess
I just have one question I the only
thing that concerns me is it the bill
doesn't
say um it says uh the independent
contract should conduct manual review of
domestic violence and stalking cases and
related criminal cases in order to
compile and collate data for statistical
analysis
I guess my only question is this doesn't
say what will be you know what data will
be captured or what
so I mean if we if we pass this bill and
the and you know it's and the $30,000 is
appropriated do we have to worry that
there's going to be a fight
among you know some interest groups
about like well capture this data but
not this data or capture you know this
much but not so I'm wondering if if if
you see that as an issue that we ought
to address perhaps by an amendment or
whatever I I would not want to speak for
the prime sponsor but it it is my
understanding that she was going to
offer an amendment once those questions
were set she had a deadline that she had
to hit with submitting the original Bill
and was working on those questions I I I
would hate to be incorrect in that but I
believe she did want to set those
questions with the universe of people
who have um been seeking data of one
kind of another and then seek it by an
amendment I think there also may be an
amendment on the funds appropriation
because um those that deal with federal
funds know that they typically have
supplantation limitations which is you
can't supplant State spending so there
is a just a little tweak that needs to
be done to one line here so that we
don't accidentally get in a situation
where we can't get federal funds or
state funds because of how it's phrased
um there there are some things coming up
in September that we could apply for but
it it just has to be phrased in such a
way that it's not supplanting okay so I
do believe there is an amendment coming
forward that would make that correction
and probably add the list of questions
for your
um just making some notes here so before
I
forget right uh questions for this
witness seeing none thank you very much
thank you all right um
is there anyone else who wishes to uh
speak on HP 762 FN Mr albre you have
something else you want to
say
sure just one followup I heard these
aren't in electronic form yet they're
regularly faxed to and from the judicial
branch so I'm curious why facts is don't
count as electronic storage and whether
any of those faxes are retained
electronically and I think that should
be addressed thank you all right thank
you very much any questions from stert
seeing none thank you is there anyone
else who wishes to testify on uh HB 762
FNA seeing none I'm going to call I'm
going to close the hearing on uh HB 762